all right let's start okay welcome to
the ddps seminar everyone before we
introduce our employees speakers let's
go over some rules and Logistics as
usual
uh first of all please mute yourself
during the token to please use chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in Q a session at the end
uh second two days today is ddps seminar
is open to external audiences so no
classified discussion is allowed please
watch out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host Dr Amir um arjani
who is a tenure track assistant
professor at the University of Utah
um you know based on the conversation I
just made I'm we are expecting him to
become a associate professor um
spring next year as a matter of fact
he obtained his Bachelor master and
Doctor degree in mechanical engineering
from
Isfahan University of Technology
Illinois Institute of Technology and UC
Berkeley respectively
is is the director of the computational
biomechanics group at Utah and the
recipient of the NSF Courier award is
research utilizes various computational
mechanics and data-driven techniques to
study biological flows and soft tissue
mechanics today
Amil will present an exciting topic
which is a flexible and generalizable
xai framework for scientific deep
learning
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further Ado let me pass the
button to Emir by asking one random
question as usual the random question is
what is your idea of the perfect day
a perfect day yeah
a perfect day is a happy day
I don't know if everything goes by plan
that's a perfect day oh yeah that that
sometimes no bad news no bad news no
Grant rejections yeah that does
sometimes happen yeah yeah okay thank
you thank you
thank you it's great to be here and I'm
excited speaking uh uh talking with all
of you so I'll be presenting our recent
work on interpretable AI
so um okay so as we all know deep
learning studies become very popular in
physics-based modeling whether that's
super resolution denoising predicting
clothes closure modeling or just the
surrogate model for in-loop calculations
like optimization or uncertainty
quantifications but there are two key
challenges in deep learning uh one is a
generalization to out of distribution
test data or really extrapolation and
the other challenge is lack of
interpretability
so interpretability is desired because
it provides trust in our models it helps
us get better fundamental understanding
of the system that we're studying and it
also helps us come up with better
debugging strategies for our models and
also out of distribution generalization
or extrapolation is desired because it
provides some level of robustness once
you want to deploy our model and that
I'll talk about that later and but I
should mention that when I talk about
extrapolation in this talk I don't mean
extrapolation to Infinity of course
that's not going to be possible unless
you're really really lucky so I really
mean some sort of you know some level of
extrapolation or accepted error once you
go outside of your training landscape
okay so this is the figure that you've
probably seen many many times in the
past couple of years so you know we can
divide scientific modeling in the age of
AI into these three broad categories you
know if you have you know all of physics
in your model and you have data just for
boundary conditions and parameters you
can do physics based modeling using
traditional solvers you know find
element or any other approach and the
choice here is usually driven by our
background training so it's really
mostly political for most of us but
approach you use or you know based on
our training and then um on the other
end you know if you have large amounts
of data deep learning is great in
interpolating uh but the mid you know
range where you have some physics and
some data is what's really interesting
so what I'd like to propose then why
don't we can also think about dividing
that mid-range into two different
categories so in one part we can think
about having lots of physics but the
physics being not enough right we might
be for example missing
um the boundary parts of the boundary
condition or sometimes it's just in but
we know the pde so when you have lots of
physics but it's just not enough and
then we have some Stars small data so
this is where you know approaches such
as physics inform neural network or
other classical data stimulation
approaches have shown to be useful in
tackling these types of problems but I'd
like to discuss another type of problem
here where we have lots of
lots of very knowledge about the
physical system so this is uh and I'll
explain in a moment what I mean by
little physics so this is what we would
like to uh focus on for today's talk
okay so what do I mean by that so in you
know a lot of times when you start to
move you know as a community as we start
to move away from 1D and 2D Benchmark
problems for scientific machine learning
and start calculating more complex
problems we will start to face this
challenge that even though we might be
able to generate large data for those
practical problems our large data might
not be large enough okay we will always
face the challenge of out of
distribution generalization or not being
to cover the landscape of all possible
behaviors so just to give you an example
in my applications I'm really interested
in cardiovascular fluid mechanics and
you know if you want to build a machine
learning circuit that truly can replace
finds volume of find element you need to
provide a mapping between the landscape
of all possible complex morphology which
3D morphologies which of the arteries
which could be really complicated and
also boundary conditions to for the
bactorial data so it's a 3D time
dependent Vector Fields right so it's a
really really difficult learning problem
even though we might be able to generate
launch data the large data might not be
large enough so now this really brings
the topic of robustness like you know it
we need to think about as we move to
practical problems and deploying deep
learning we need to think about how
robust it is so you know we can think
about it two ways one is that you can
think about in some applications you
might not know exactly the boundary of
the training landscape it might be a
little bit blurred so you know don't
exactly know if you're in distribution
or out of distribution when you're
deploying the model or in some cases
your deep learning model is operating in
in Loop calculations for example you
have a multi-scale model it's
optimization problem so your deep
learning model is coupled to a
traditional physics-based solver and you
don't really have control over what that
physics-based solver is sending into
your deep learning model right so you
want to have some level of robustness of
like let's imagine like the
physics-based solver is sending
something that perturbs the model to out
of distribution you want to make sure
you provide some level of acceptable
error for your deep learning model now
what do I mean by little physics I
talked about we can think about that in
two different ways let's think about it
that in certain
deep learning architectures it might be
difficult to regularize for all the
physics right you might know the physics
for the problem you're solving but it's
just it might be that it makes the
training process difficult or it might
be difficult depending on what type of
machine learning problem we're doing to
regularize at least for all the physics
that we know or we could also think
about cases where we don't really know
much about physics except some very
little knowledge so for example you
might only know symmetry we might know
that you know points if a point is close
to a point that we're interested in the
input space that has a higher influence
and the output or we might note that our
problem belongs to broadcast of
operators so this is what we're going to
be leveraging today and what I mean by
you know small knowledge a little
knowledge of physics okay now so uh so
the summary here is that we need some
level of acceptable error in
extrapolation and this really brings us
to the topic of in my opinion robust
scientific machine learning which is one
of the priority research directions
actually based on 2019 reports of doing
scientific machine learning okay now
let's start talking about out of
distribution generalization so there are
different ways to improve out of
distribution generalization in the
literature and but a lot of these
approaches required to retrain your
machine learning model and they might
not have limited accuracy so our
question was that can we do improve out
of distribution generalization and note
that I'm using the word improve I'm not
arguing that we're trying to have very
very good errors for extrapolation
that's just too difficult so can we
improve the accuracy for adult
distribution generalization given a
train neural network as a
post-processing step okay so that's the
question now the way we propose to do
that is inspired by the process of human
thinking so let me explain that suppose
you're studying for an exam okay and the
way you're studying for an exam is a
data-driven approach as opposed to
physics based so what I mean is that
you're only studying sample a prior exam
questions you're not studying the
lecture notes okay so if you go to an
exam you uh you know you see a question
that's exactly the same as the sample
exams you studied you know you can
quickly write the answer but that's the
training data just like have a neural
network works if you see a question
that's similar to what you studied but
not quite the same that's what we call
in distribution test data and as long as
you've learned something meaningful you
should be able to write the answer
quickly again similar to a neural
network as long as the neural network
doesn't just memorize the labels it
learns some meaningful pattern it should
do a good job with interpolation now the
third scenario is the tricky one if you
see a question on the exam that's
completely different from the sample
questions you studied what would you do
and this is the out of distribution test
problem
so what you probably would do is that
some sort of thinking right you would
probe your brain based on the sample
questions you study right and try to use
those sample questions you study that
you're probing your brain it's some sort
of interpretation and reasoning together
with any prior knowledge you have to
answer that new question so this is
exactly what we wanted to do so give me
a trained neural network that's already
trained what I'm going to do is that I'm
gonna probe it within its landscape of
training you know provide them give it a
bunch of inputs within the landscape of
training It's Quickly going to produce
outputs so generate that data set then
what I'm going to do is that I'm gonna
fit an interpretable model to that which
I'll talk about how I do that so some
sort of it's going to be some sort of
sparse kernel regression with the
library of integral equations and then
fit that interpretable model in the form
of some of internal equations which I'll
discuss in a moment and use that to add
answer the out of distribution input
that's being that we're being asked okay
so now the question becomes how do we
build that interpretable model
this brings us to the topic of
interpretable unexplainable AI which is
a topic in deep learning we could
broadly categorize XI into two
broadcaster approaches
by Design approaches and post hoc so in
by Design what we do is that we
incorporate interpretability right from
the beginning in the design of the
architectural machine learning model so
examples of that in our community
perhaps Cindy is the most you know
familiar example where it's you can
think of it as a by Design XLR approach
symbolic regression is perhaps another
example and you can also even do by
Design xai and a neural network where
you essentially Define some
interpretability loss and you penalize
for interpretability during your
learning and then you have the second
class of X-ray problems you should call
them post hoc and the way they work is
that they essentially do the
interpretation as a post-processing step
okay so they interpret the black spots
model as a post processing step so the
issue with by Design approaches is that
they limit expressive power right
there's no free lunch if you build a
model it's very interpretable you might
not be able to fit complex data sets and
the issue with postlock approaches don't
have that issue because they do it as a
post-processing step but the problem
there is that
um there's usually no code they explain
a given in input okay
so now our idea was that can we and some
examples of postdoc approaches are
gradient-based approaches where you just
use the back propagate the gradient and
the surrogate for explaining which
feature is more important or also there
are some other approaches where you take
an input that you're interested in
explaining and you just perturb it fit a
linear model to that and explain that at
the neural network is uh making
predictions based on a specific input
okay so these are some photoshop
approaches so our idea was that can
so it could be
a post-hoc or by Design okay we have
this very minimal effort and change in
the infrastructure
okay
um now the key idea that motivates us is
through Theory so I'll explain what I
call this Theory guided machine learning
in a moment but uh think about the
certain Concepts like greens functions
is one example so you know when you're
dealing with the pte of this form you
know you're given an input forcing
function f you want to solve for U if
your PD operator is linear you can you
know you have a corresponding inverse to
that which is what we call the greens
function so essentially you can take
your input integrate it over some green
function which is like a kernel and get
your output okay or solve the problem
and um interestingly if you look at
convolutional neural networks there's
something similar kind of hidden in
there so the the convolution operations
that we have in different layers of a
convolutional neural networks they're
also based on some sort of similar
integral equations where you can think
about convolving your input going to
that layer with some kernel function
okay of course there's more cnns are
much more complex than that but that's
inside that's also happening inside them
and also you know if you're familiar
with radial basis functions Downstream
processes that use squared exponential
kernel functions you know again similar
ideas we have in those types of uh
problems and finally you know neural
operators very hot topic these days a
certain class of neural operators they
also leverage certain similar idea but
there you know you're doing it in
multiple layers with neural networks so
you're kind of losing the
interpretability of course you're
getting better expressive power so now
um
so it seems like integral equations are
a key in providing mapping between
functions so what we want to do is that
we want to use them for interpretation
so now before I proceed I want to make
this you know link here is that what I
think really what we're doing here in
building the interpretable machine
learning model is that we can think of
this as some sort of theory guided
machine learning so you know what I just
explained here is some sort of theory
guiding us how we set up our machine
learning model so now you know if you
think about machine learning scientific
machine learning problems you know
either you can think about physics
informed machine learning like pins in
these cases the physics is typically uh
you know as a loss function you you kind
of like regularize the problem with the
loss function that's your physics so
that's physics inform machine learning
and then you can also think about Theory
guided machine learning where
essentially in these types of problems
the physics or theory is guiding how you
set up your machine learning model how
you design your machine learning
architecture that's motivated by the
theory or the physics so one example of
that is one of our recent words where we
developed this financial physics inform
neural networks which you can think
about it integrating both physics inform
machine learning
where you build the architecture of your
PIN neural network such that you're
replicating classical mathematics Theory
so in this case those perturbation
Theory and asymptotic expansion so
you're setting up this Ensemble neural
networks to essentially do what you know
old school classical perturbation
through your asymptotic expansion does
and that enables you to solve very thin
and Boundary layer problems that you
cannot do with a regular peanut approach
so that's kind of you know what we're
also trying to motivate you by is that
letting Theory guide us how we design
our machine learning problem
okay so now the way we're going to do
that in this case is through functional
data analysis so FDA is a branch of
Statistics that analyzes data in the
form of functions rather than discrete
data so essentially what we're
interested in doing here is that give me
an input function f
and an output U that could either be a
function itself or it could be as simply
a single value or functional so I'd like
to find a mapping between the input
function to that
and the way we do this in FDA is through
what's called functional linear models
essentially you define these integral
equations that takes you from input to
the output which the output again is
either a function itself or a single
scalar value so now the the goal in the
functional linear models and functional
data analysis is to find this kernel
sign so that's the goal here the current
approach is the way they do that is that
they either predefine the kernel or they
use some expansions to find it but you
know the challenge here is that the
precise choice of the kernel is not
really clear you know this is a very
nice model it's interpretable it's
analytic right but the precise choice of
this kernel that can provide that
mapping for you that is not very clear
and also a single choice or on a fully
linear model like what you're seeing in
this equation might not be sufficient to
it might not have sufficient expressive
power to fit complex data so what should
we do uh before I personally if you're
interested in functional data analysis
these are two excellent textbooks
written on the topic that I highly
recommend them
okay so what we propose is some sort of
generalized FDA okay where we generalize
this to provide some more expensive
powers and we do that in three steps one
we provide the option that we lift the
input functions okay so we can either
use polynomials and exponentials so we
leave the input functions to create new
features so that you know gives some
sort of non-linearity and increase
expressive power
the second thing we do is that we
provide the option for each of these
integral terms to add in non-linearity
so nonlinear function G could be applied
to the output of the integral equation
and you can think of this as an
activation function so it's pretty
similar to an activation function okay
um and the third thing we do is that we
essentially build a library of various
choices of integral equations and this
could be based on different kernels
different choices of non-linearity and
um lifting and also different bandwidth
parameters within each kernel so you
build this larger library and use sparse
regression okay use password regression
to select a set of these integral
equations and you linearly add them so
really the goal is to find this linear
coefficients w i so essentially the
final model will look something like
this it's a linear sum of
integral equations uh so you can think
of it as a generalized functional linear
model and you know it's still linear
though with respect to its unknown
parameters wi but you've added some
non-linearity within demand so now the
nice thing about this is that for each
term in this model you can interpret
basically based on the Kernel that you
have the kernel will tell you how
important effect of a certain point at
the input is on a certain other point at
the output and in the case where you're
where your output is a single value
single Vector scalar field this cannot
provide some sort of rate for the effect
of input and out okay so you can and
also these coefficients provide you know
how important each term is so you can
have some sort of interpretability in
this model
okay now there are some other advantages
with this approach this is completely
analytical right so you can if if you're
defining these kernels that are
differentiable so the integral equations
are differentiable you can take
derivatives okay so that provides lots
of Advantage opportunities for doing
exciting things that you need
derivatives another Advantage is that
you can infer any point you don't need
to interpolate because this is kind of
like an analytical model you can even
though you train at certain points
you're not bound to those certain points
you can you know evaluate any point in
between without the need of
interpolation and finally again going
back to the totally guided idea you know
the field of classical mathematics you
know integral equations are well
established topics and again an old
school Topic in mathematics we have
approaches for solving integral
equations we have theorems so there's
lots of idea you know opportunities to
kind of Link those classical
mathematical theories within the
integral equation work to you know this
model
or extend those terms
okay so now here's a summary of the
Final Approach so what we do is that we
have a chain neural network okay and we
prove it based on different inputs
within its landscape of training and we
fit this interpretable model to it and
we call that neural network we can also
do this directly Based on data so forget
about the neural network I want to do it
directly Based on data I can do the same
thing directly based on training data
this is what I call data driven
interpretable model and you can think of
the second approach as a by Design
approach the first approach as a post
hoc approach so yeah so now what you do
is you build this large Library this is
very similar to Cindy by the way if you
haven't noticed already you build a
large library of different forms of
integral equations with different
non-linearities lifting different
kernels different hyper parameters
you've built this large library and then
what you do is that you have your data
and you do sponsor regression actually
just pass regression and you find these
coefficients W that you see here and
then eventually you write your
interpretable circuit model as a sum of
integral equations and you can see this
sum is over all possible lifting
operations on the inputs all possible
kernels and all possible
predefined activation functions if you
like or non-linearities through this G
function
okay so
um now just for your reference these are
some of the examples of some of these uh
you know integral equations that we
provide in that large Library
okay now how do you find those
coefficients you know our goal now is
really to find these coefficients and
once you find these coefficients we are
you know we have our you know analytical
circuit model so how do we do that so
two approaches you can do that one is
sparse regression by you solving this L1
regularized uh regression problem this
is exactly again similar to Cindy and
the Lambda parameter here provides a
trade-off between interpretability and
accuracy in your regression problem the
second choice you have is to do an L2
regularization which might in certain
problem provide better uh accuracy and
in this case the nice thing about this
Ultra regularization is that you have
closed form solution right so you can
form this normal equations and you know
you have a closed form solution to this
optimization problem and but the issue
here is that this F transport F Matrix
is usually highly highly ill conditions
so you need to have major use robust uh
linear solvers that can somehow you know
mitigate this ill-condition issue and in
this case in this L2 regularization case
you can think about the Lambda parameter
providing a Trader between
accuracy of your regression and
robustness of your linear solver because
as you increase Lambda your linear
solder will have an easier job
converging okay
uh so now once we find these coefficient
and we find our interpretable model how
do we use that so there are three broad
applications that I can think about or
discuss here today one is you know you
can use this model as a post-hoc black
box interpretation that is give me a
neural network I probe it within its
training landscape or I can probably
just locally if I like I can even just
probe the neural network in out of
distribution regime to kind of
understand how it's behaving in out of
distribution or in extrapolation
problems so I do that and then I fit my
interpretable model to that probe data
and those probe data are quickly done
we're here we're just inferring the
neural network is already trained so
it's quickly you know inferring and
producing those probe data so this is
what I call neural network driven in the
results
the second uh application you could use
this as a by Design x-ray approach
meaning that you forget about the neural
network you directly train this model on
training data so there's no deep
learning involved in this case and this
one I called it data driven
interpretable model and this third case
you can think about as a hybrid
Computing strategy
which means that if you have you know
you develop a cyber infrastructure where
you can somehow tell what is in
distribution what is out of distribution
with some algorithm and if you have an
in-distribution input you use a neural
network if you have an out of
distribution input you call the
interpretable model so this is some sort
of hybrid Computing strategy
okay I want to talk about this in the
results today so I'll talk about the
first and second one okay here's just a
quick motivation examples just to show
you that how deep Learning Works in out
of distribution so you know this is just
a 1D function so you have this dashed
blue lines being the function and
imagine our training data just placed
here right and we fit a neural network
to it so the green line is the neural
network so you know obviously it's a
simple 1D problem it will do a perfect
job fitting the data but as soon as you
go outside so if you focus on the right
hand side here as soon as you go outside
of the training lines get your quickly
off right but if you if you use a more
interpretable model so in this case a
gaussian process regression you can see
that if you look at this right side here
you can see that the gaussian process
which is the green line does a better
job compared to what you saw on the left
with the neural network in terms of at
least extrapolating a little bit better
so this is one of one motivation for us
to go for more interpretable models in
extrapolation
okay so let's get to the exam this is
the first example this is the solid
mechanics example where we want to
predict strain energy and from a
heterogeneous material
so in all the examples I'm going to
present today we used Phoenix for
generating the training data so Phoenix
is an open source uh find element solver
that we use uh so in this case we use
the mechanical Ms and MNS data that was
uh and as that was provided to us it's
an open source data set by the way so
you know we work with our collaborators
who developed this and essentially the
idea is that we're using the classical
MNS and MNS uh data in machine learning
where you have this handwritten digits
and letters and we're defining a mapping
to convert the pixel bitmaps to an
elastic modulized essentially using this
equation so basically you take the
bitmaps of the image you convert it to
an elastic modulator now you have a
heterogeneous material and you have to
stretch it and in this problem you're
interested in the straight errors so
this is the mapping between an image to
a single band okay and this parameter s
if you change the parameter s you're
going to shift this mapping so you can
generate out of distribution data so
that's how we generated out of
distribution data here so now the
results that you see you're going to be
seeing the next few examples these are a
box plot of the errors aggregated over
all the data points and we're going to
have on the left three are going to be
the neural network training regime the
error for the interpretable model driven
by the neural network interpretable
model directly trained on data and
training and on the right is test and by
test here I mean out of distribution
tests so what you see in testing all the
fears are really extrapolation
okay so what do we see here what we see
here is that
that visual model
s this box plug error that the errors
are going down when you use these
interpretable models in the
extrapolation regime and I forgot to say
that these red dots that you see in
these box plots these are outliers so
the red box red dots are the outliers
for the error distribution
and what we also seen this problem is
that in the training side in this
specific case interpretable models have
comparable accuracy compared to the uh
to the neural network
so here's a second example we this is
the porous media flow we want to predict
velocity fields from a heterogeneous
permeability film so this is a problem
where you're mapping an image to an
image okay so your input is the
permeability an image of the
permeability field which we Define using
this equation and by varying the
coefficients A and B we can you know
generate training data and if I select
the A and B coefficients to go outside
of the region used for training now I'm
generating out of distribution data
uh so um so you want to go from its
permeability mapping to the velocity
Fields so if you look at the results
here
um what we see is that the interpretable
model again improves the out of
distribution generalization error and
also you can see in this case that you
know of course as you expect no the
neural network training error is better
than the interpretable models inside the
training regime but interestingly you
can see that outliers are a little bit
reduced by interpretable models for the
training data
okay so here's another example so this
example is more motivated by the type of
work that I do so this is a predicting
Wall Street stress in a blood flow
problem based on low Fidelity data so
the motivation here is that low Fidelity
flow data are easy to generate whether
that's computational using a you know a
course dissipative solver it's really
easy to generate that data or
experimental if you have a you know
experimental measurement that's not very
accurate you know uh you know you're
generating really low Fidelity data and
also another motivation for this test
case problem is that if you're
interested in measuring fluid flow data
near the wall especially if you have
complex geometries that's a challenging
task so in cardiovascular flow problems
we're often interested in one shot
stress but measuring one shear stress
experimental is difficult because we
have the wall interference there and
also computationally getting accurate
while Shield stress data requires you to
do boundary layer machine having a fine
mesh near the wall so that's also a
little bit more challenging so the idea
was that can we find a mapping between
low Fidelity data that's that's measured
away from the wall into high quality
water system
so the problem we look at is a 2d flow
so the flow is going probably left to
right we have a constricted vessel
mimicking like a you know blocked
archery and for a low Fidelity data we
have cfd simulations with a very coarse
mesh in this case just 500 elements and
we also increase viscosity in this case
we ramped up viscosity by 20 to
represent a dissipative stimulation and
you know just FYI this is actually in
some problems a common thing to do in
some low Fidelity solutions for example
in stopping a high Schmidt number
adventure and diffusion pdes often you
know in the cardiovascular applications
they picked the number and Smith numbers
are just so large that solving it's just
so difficult so often people just
increase the diffusion coefficient to
make it typically it's able to solve the
problem basically so that's what we call
low Fidelity data so we want to map that
no Fidelity data to High Fidelity uh
Water Shield stress daytime for training
we generated quality data with a high
resolution uh solver 40 000 elements and
we also use p2p1 elements so quadratic
shape functions for velocity
this is what we call the High Fidelity
solution strategy so just to give you an
idea this is what the low Fidelity mesh
looks like you know very coarse and this
is what the low Fidelity fluid results
look like you're looking at the velocity
magnitude so you want to map the
velocity industry it away from the wall
to High Fidelity Wireless
okay so here's the results so we have in
the training data we train over a
certain range of Millennials numbers and
for out of distribution we're going to
higher rails numbers so in this case we
also within 250 240 and 300 so you're
extrapolating the rails number basically
for out of distribution
and the goal is to map a low Fidelity
velocity field that might look something
like this into a high fidelity water
should stress at the wall and this is
also an example of a co-dimension one
mapping so in this in the previous
examples we either mapped an image to a
single value or an image to an image but
in this case we're mapping an image to a
line okay now in this case if you look
at the errors the training errors are
really small compared to the
extrapolation error so if you zoom into
them this is what you see you can see um
you have training accuracy that's even
slightly better at least for the data
driven interpretable model interestingly
in this case compared to the neural
network and if you look at the
extrapolation case which is what you see
here you can see that you know that it's
you're significant getting reduced
extrapolation error for the vast
majority of the data and you have
slightly higher extrapolation errors for
your outliers in the for a few other
players in the in the interpretable
modes
okay so here's another example this is
the same problem but let's say instead
of mapping the low Fidelity velocity to
High Fidelity one is your stress why
don't we map the low Fidelity velocity
to Hype it a little bit so this is this
mapping you want to go from this low
Fidelity velocity to this High Fidelity
velocity and interestingly in this case
what we see if we look at the results is
that we cannot we couldn't solve this
problem
so the at the out of distribution test
test did not improve for the
interpretable model in this case and you
know I like this example because it
reminds us that there's no theoretical
guarantee you know and I just I'm not
aware of any theoretical guarantee that
you can guarantee that by using an
interpretable model you can get improved
generalization so you know we really
need to understand when do such
approaches work and when do they fail so
that's you know something that we still
need to work on
okay so this is an example where
essentially the method didn't provide
improved extrapolation
okay so the final example is just to
show you that we can also do local
interpretation so we don't have to so in
all the previous examples we broke the
entire landscape of training so with the
interpretable model was fit to the
entire training landscape but you don't
necessarily need to do that if you're
interested just an interpretation if
you're interested in generalization you
have to do that you have to learn the
entire landscape so then you can push it
a little bit further and extrapolate but
if you're not interested in
extrapolation you only want to explain
behavior you might want to do that
locally because you're going to get a
more accurate fit and also likely it's
going to be easier to fit a more
interpretable model today so that's what
this example is
um
so we provide a mapping between the
modified permeability field to uh to the
velocity magnitude and we change the
permeability so the permeability
permeable region the police region is
only confined to this black region here
I mean the training region will be a
change at not only the uh the equation
but also the shape of the super you know
this porous region so then what we see
here is that you know we get a good uh
you know the training error that we get
for the interpretable model that's
driven by the neural network it's
comparable to the neural network you can
see that the training error in this case
for the data driven model is much much
smaller this shouldn't be surprising
because in this case the data driven
interpretable model is just fit to local
data
whereas the neural network is fit to the
large larger Landscapes that's why the
because between local interpretation
here so that's why the data driven one
has better error and you can also see
that they have good error with respect
to the neural network
uh so so you know local interpretation
is essentially
easier to do it's an easier
interpretation task okay so to summarize
we developed an interpretable framework
for interpreting and generalizing deep
learning the framework is flexible you
could apply it local Global or post-hoc
or by Design the framework
in most examples we studied it reduced
extrapolation error and you know it
could it had you know in most cases
again comparable training accuracies at
least for a simple problem to study but
there are several challenges that remain
you know how we Define that library of
integral equations that's one challenge
again very similar thing as Sydney
um another challenge that when you go to
more complex problems how do you define
in distribution and out of distribution
it might not be trivial in our case we
had some parameters that change within a
range so it was trivial but in some more
complex problems it might not be trivial
uh another thing is that you could have
um you know really all these regression
problems there's a trade-off between uh
explanation how interpretable your model
is and how accurate it extrapolates we
saw that trade-off in the problems we
studied
um and also we don't really know when
this method works and maybe but it
doesn't work so that's you know more to
be done there and also we could extend
think about extending this to other
problems time dependent problems
parametric problems you know in
functional data analysis there's also
approaches to do parametric functional
mapping you can also think about inverse
problems in physics inform problems so
there are several ways you can think
about extending this one okay and more
details on this paper and archive and um
if you have any questions I'll be happy
to answer them thank you
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful program yeah
um I enjoyed it a lot I'm sure um
you know a lot of other people has
enjoyed the life uh let's have a q a
sessions
um there are some questions in in the
chat uh the first one I see is by Chris
he was asking how is outlier defined so
the outliers I think that's the default
definition of a box plot but usually so
it's in this case it was a values larger
than 1.5 times the interquartile range
basically uh in kind of like the default
definition of a box plot you generate I
think in math level python sounds good
okay uh second question
uh in the chat uh by
um run up
um he asked are the out of distribution
points
chosen taking into account bifurcation
points or how do you tackle the
bifocation points when you choose the
out of distribution testing Rings that's
a good question I didn't think about
that so by bifurcation assume you mean
like in from a dynamical systems
perspective and you go out you know
change a parameter the system suddenly
becomes completely different right you
go from certain stabilities to other
stability properties yeah that's a great
question I never thought about that so
that's you know I would I think you know
in this case it's you know I don't think
a bifurcation happens I can imagine if
it happens you have no luck yeah
I can think about that uh so I think
that's a good point uh I don't think if
this approach will work if you buy for
you have bifurcation once you go outside
your parameter
I mean bifurcation is
it's completely different animal
um
it's not I don't think we can consider
it out of distribution
in data-driven contexts oh yeah anyway
okay so next question is by gaurav uh he
asked what is a training data sample
velocity field sample or something else
and how do we determine as to how much
data is sufficient for training okay
good question so no point
training
was between
exact numbers of how many data sets we
had was in the paper but usually on the
order of hundreds
or I think in some cases even thousand
samples we use the details on the
archive paper but and they were like
automated so in Phoenix you can easily
automate your solver change the
parameter and quickly generate all these
training data especially for these 2D
problems uh but so the way you define
training is by changing spam materials
or in certain cases multiple parameters
for example in this case we change not
only this coefficient in the
permeability field but also the shape of
the permeability zone so that's based on
the radius and also the center of this
sphere that you see here so there's
essentially there's a two or three
parameters basically that you know
find you have a range that's the
training you go outside that range and
that becomes extractable
all right
um another questions by six Scott uh he
has all your examples you you didn't
show the corner functions for the
interpretable models so I think that's
reporting the paper but you know here I
have an appendix so this is all the
parallel functions we used uh for uh
image to image or image to scalar
mappings so just to give you an idea
what type of candles we're dealing with
Just note that these better parameters
you see here these are the bandwidths of
the kernel which are very very important
right so we Define a range for them and
you can be you can the selection of the
bandwidth you can also be guided by some
optimal bandwidth selection methods we
talked about that in the paper so you
have to not only Define different
kernels but also different bandwidths
that's what essentially makes up the
library so you know so this is this is
this is the library library that I'm
talking about
all right sounds good mostly looks like
it's a delusion type of column so mostly
it's radial basis function type kernels
like yeah
yeah all right sounds good uh I don't
see any other
um questions in the Q a but I I do have
a some questions so in the beginning of
the presentations you talked about the
the by designs yeah
you said it's it's limiting the
expressibility
um
but I I don't know it's a maybe the
difference in the opinion I I wouldn't
say that's limiting the expressibility I
would say limiting the over
parameterization so because a lot of
neural network
um you know taking advantage of the over
parametrization you introduce like
millions millions of the primary and you
try to come up with a some fine-tuned
parameter of its maps that it fits the
data so think about it this way
I think by let's say you have a third
order polynomial and your body is
all right so you don't have the
expressive power to fit a cubic
polynomial because you're only going up
to you know quadratic but in neural
network will automatically be able to
you know fit that because it has you
know the universal approximation Theory
so that's really what we mean but of
course you can you always push the by
Design approach to be more and more and
more accurate by expanding you know but
depending on how you're doing it but
yeah I'm talking about in the context of
how you know improving the out of uh
distribution accuracy generalization so
you know one way of doing it is you know
you start with the over parameterized
neural network right and then but a lot
of times over parameterization is
acceptable to the overfitting so which
is not good for the generalized and
generalization so so from that
pre-trained model you you can reduce
that your you know the size of the
parameterizations hoping that that will
improve the general uh generalization I
agree yeah yeah
um oh okay yeah so in that sense I
wouldn't say that's limiting the
expressibility I would say it's my
expressibility I mean in distribution
training regime like training labels
putting training labels basically
all right
you have limited ability to precisely
fit your training by by Design
approaches versus a black Boxer
okay while we are talking uh there is
another question by gaurav since
generation of 3DD data can be
computationally expensive are there any
videos to the models with the 3D data
built based on this approach
reduce order models built based on this
approach uh
and that's exactly sure so what do you
mean but uh
do you want to mute yourself and then
yes I I was just trying to say that a
lot of the times generating 3D data just
a single snapshot can be very very
expensive
uh so I was just saying that for the
functional data analysis approach that
you talked about where you were training
it on some 2D data I definitely saw but
uh is there any example for a 3D
simulation or a more realistic
simulation yeah so you could extend it
to 3D but you'll just have volumetric
insiders over insert area integrals we
haven't done that yet but you could no
the theoretical extension of course it
will be computationally more expensive
you know it's a little bit more
difficult and all of that but you know
from at least pure Theory point of view
it's just now you have volumetric
integrals instead of 2D integrals
but we haven't done that
sounds good okay I have one going back
to my question
um
so when you introduce G FDA
um what does g stand for like STD stands
for function data analysis oh
generalized okay
um there
um I do see that
um you know
this steps is very similar to
um finding the cool man operator
um are you familiar with that yes yes
yes yes yeah so um basically what they
do is you know you have a you know some
data and then you try to lift that into
by introducing you know use that feature
here uh but the you know
technically unlimited number of you know
non-linear map of that original data to
you know to increase the size of the
data and then
um in theory there is always the linear
operator which can you know map those
Dynamics right yes yes you're right so
essentially you're absolutely right so
we essentially this is also a form of
operator learning problem really yeah
and and also it's also similar to the
lift and learn approach in ROMs by Karen
Wilcox
yeah exactly you also do the same thing
you lift your input functions and you
know you come up with more accurate
problems I mean yeah I mean the Kumon
operator focusing on the the linear
operator
um the lift land you know what they are
doing with the caramel cooks and their
colleagues
um you know some are focusing on the
quadratic modeling yeah but you you're
you know generalized to that particular
uh model uh form but you know with this
non-linearity introduced by you like the
through G functions there
um
yeah that was very interesting
um you know the command operator was the
first thing I you know
sort of you know we're gonna look at
this slide another
a question I have is you know you you
introduce the the Cindy type of this um
you know The Spar side and
identification the Dynamics
identification model in order to improve
the interview interpretability
um and I the one thing is you use the
integral form
um not the strong form just like this
have you
um
are you familiar with the weak Cindy
yeah yes work yes that's what they do
um they they take the integral form yes
and
so yeah a big Singapore if I remember
correctly that's based on the weak form
of the pde where you multiply exactly
integration by parts so you're learning
it in the big form sense in a strong
form but here you're not assuming any
knowledge of you know you're not
learning a pde in this case you're
learning an operator
between
they both used
to use yeah integral equations and they
use the data too I mean the recently
uses the data as well so
so uh I do see the another similarity
between those two
yeah very interesting uh while we are
discussing to do we have another uh
question in Q a uh in chat no I don't
see that okay let's open to the audience
is there anyone who
um who would like to Omit yourself and
you know ask questions directly
no well
then let's thank our speaker today uh
for the wonderful talk and wonderful q a
sessions I you know it's it's really
exciting oh and you you raise your hand
or do you have a question oh okay the
clapping
all right uh with that let's
um you know let's wrap up the uh
the seminar today well thank you so much
emmya thank you thanks for having me
thank you yeah
expect